merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à manuel valls premier
ministre ce samedi à calais se sont
déroulé des faits d'une exceptionnelle
gravité
le port a été de nouveau pris d'assaut
l'activité économique une nouvelle fois
bloqué des personnes et des biens ont
été menacés la statue du général de
gaulle soulier l'autorité républicaine
défier est bafouée face à ces événements
qui sont malheureusement pas les
premiers le sentiment des calaisiens et
des français c'est que la situation
échappe désormais à tout contrôle
dans le clan lalande qui est devenu le
plus grand bidonville d'europe c'est
désormais le chaos et la loi des
passeurs qui règne face à cette
situation insoutenable
les calaisiens ont jusqu'à présent gardé
leur sang froid
je veux saluer ici leur réaction digne
et exemplaire
dimanche aux côtés de natacha bouchart
maire de calais ils ont de nouveau
manifesté pour dire qu'ils aiment leur
ville
qu'elle est belle mais qui n'en peuvent
plus que chaque semaine son image soit
dégradée que chaque semaine les
entreprises et l'emploi se déstabiliser
et l'insécurité aggravé député du pas de
calais je veux faire cet après midi le
porte parole des calaisiens des
habitants la côte d'opale et de ceux qui
demandent au gouvernement de plus
minimisé l'ampleur du phénomène
monsieur le premier ministre en date ils
attendent un drame qu'a drame survienne
pour qu'enfin le président la république
se rende sur place
monsieur prémunissent qu'attendez vous
pour prendre des mesures exceptionnelles
qui permettront de rétablir les lois de
la république et de mettre fin à cette
situation de non droit
monsieur prémunissent que proposez-vous
pour expulser les clandestins pour
sanctionner des no border complice de
ces violences et pour traiter dignement
les vrais demandeurs d'asile monsieur le
premier ministre il est plus que temps
que vous réagissiez câble comme l'a dit
hier notre nouveau président région
xavier bertrand calais c'est la france
et la france ne peut plus accepter ces
situations
merci la parole et à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur oui
monsieur le député fasquelle vous avez
raison de citer le président de région
xavier bertand j'étais avec lui ce matin
à lille nous avons fait une conférence
de presse commune et le ton sur lequel
il est intervenu et en contraste complet
avec les aspects polémique de votre
question je voudrais répondre très
précis oui parce que plus on est près
d'un territoire et des problèmes et plus
on est éloigné de la polémique je vais
donc répondre très précisément à chacune
de vos interrogations d'abord vous dit
qu'est ce que vous faites pour éloigner
ceux qui sont en situation régulière et
qui ne relèvent pas de l'asile en voir
si vous oubliez simplement de préciser
qu'au cours de l'année 2015
ce sont 1768 migrants en situation
irrégulière ont été expulsés de calais
le dire ça aurait été une bonne manière
de rendre hommage aux policiers de la
police de l'air et des frontières et aux
forces de l'ordre qui font un travail
remarquable et auquel vous n'avez même
pas rendu hommage dans votre question ce
qui est vraiment très regrettable
vous dites ensuite qu'est ce que vous
faites pour démanteler les filières de
l'immigration irrégulière
l'an dernier nous avons démantelé 25% de
plus de filière de migrants irréguliers
et deux passeurs à calais s'ils
représentent près de 700 passeurs dont
la situation a été judiciariser pourquoi
est-ce que vous ne le dites pas tout
simplement parce que vous cherchez la
polémique vous ne cherchez pas être de
bonne foi vous le cherchez pas apaisé
sur ce sujet vous dites que sur la lande
la situation s'est détériorée mais pour
ce qu est ce que vous ne dites pas
qu'avec la maire de calais et le député
yann capet et la concours de l'union
européenne
nous avons mis en place des dispositifs
imany terre sur la lande qui nous ont
conduits à mobiliser près de 20 millions
d'euros
1500 places pour ceux qui sont en
situation d'être accueillis à calais ce
qui n'existait pas avant et que vous
auriez pu valoriser
si vous étiez dans la recherche de la
vérité plutôt que dans la recherche de
la polémique
en fait la situation à calais appel de
la fermeté et dimanche et samedi
il y a eu des interpellations 35 il ya
eu si elle mise en examen et le droit
est passé à prague et à madame annie le
houérou